hello
my name is navid i will be talking about
our paper variant obviously dimension
with applications to the depth three
circuits
joint work with peter frankel and slava
kriasnov
let's recall vc dimension which is a
fundamental concept from learning theory
originally but also in combinatorics
given a family of substance of
an end element universe
we say that a subset is shattered by
this family if
the intersection of
this set with uh
with the family produces all possible
subsets
you view this family as a as a subset of
the boolean cube it means that on that
particular set of coordinates you can
see the
all the boolean cube and we call this
shattered
we see dimension
named after
its inventors bapnic and sherwin and
case
is the size of the largest such set such
a set of coordinates for for a family
and um
it's a measure of complexity of the
census
because
if you contain if if you have some
coordinates which contains a large sub-q
it sort of says that you have some level
of freedom there
a very natural and basic question is to
relate the dimension the vc dimension of
the system to its size so how large can
a set be
with a given vc dimension
and this was answered by several people
it's commonly
now attributed to sar and shella
um
which gives the following bound that if
the vc dimension is at most d
then
uh
you can we can bound the family as a sum
of binomial coefficients up to up to d
and this is tight it's very easy to see
that this is tight
because you can just take the
hamming
hamming ball
of radius d and the it's easy to see
that it's vc dimension is exactly d
this is a very useful bound and um
[Music]
in applications that i'm interested in
uh it's usually enough because if you
have an exponential size family then
this bound already implies that the vcdm
engine is linear
so that's that's good
but sometimes we want more
uh it would have been nice if you could
guarantee that uh the the larger the
family
is
the closer we would actually get to end
but of course it's not possible because
uh this star shall
cannot guarantee anything over and over
two so this is sort of the barrier of
sour sarochella and vc name engine
and we can see this by considering the
hamming ball of radius segment n over
two so this has essentially
this is a constant fraction of the
boolean cube but its vc dimension is
only a number two so we cannot guarantee
anything beyond over n over two
um
so the our starting point or or the
natural question is whether
um
we can somehow
uh get around this of course it's not
possible because you know this is uh
this says that
it's just this is an impossibility
statement but
can we can we do something about this
and the answer is yes if we change
the notion of vc dimension
so we're going to now consider a
notion of dimension which is which i
find very natural
and it does allow us to
to beat this number two barrier
we call this new damage in universal
dimension for reasons that you will see
so once again we have
a family
now we're not interested in a shattered
subset of coordinates but rather
an are universal subset of coordinates
okay so we're looking at we're we're
interested in substantive coordinates
where every subset of size that most r
is shattered by f
and we call this this uh size of such a
large as such a subset the universal r
dimension
and
well it just follows from definition
that um
this is at least we see them engine in
when the parameters are
know we're in the correct uh parameter
regime
uh so there's a hope that maybe we can
prove better so our shoulder type levels
for this for this quantity
okay so
can what is the analog of source hello
for this notion of the image
let's call this quantity u of n k r so
this is the largest
um
the cardinality of uh the largest
cardinality of a system
with uh from the end element
universe obviously that of you are
diminished and most k
and
we answer this by going to hypergraphs
and independent sets in hypergraphs
there are various ways of defining
independent sets in hypergrass where we
would take the weakest one which is so
and
a set is independent if it does not
contain any edge
so for instance these black nodes they
do not contain any of these uh
hyper edges of size three
okay
um an independence number is the of
course largest
the size of the largest independent set
and
[Music]
what we're interested in is the maximum
number of
the total number of independences the
maximum
total number of independent sets in a
hyper graph
in an uh argument from hypergraph
where the independent set is bounded by
k
so it's a toronto problem if you
remember to run to run type questions so
this is basically asked uh what is the
smallest number of edges achieving uh
achieving this
but we are asking for the total number
of independent
sets and
we show that these questions are
equivalent and this follows from
an an old technique of frankl
it's a squishy a squashing argument
so this allows us this argument allows
us to
um
we can basically assume that we our
family a family of maximum cardinality
is downward close that if
you know the sub if infinite set is in
the system then all its subsets are also
in the system
and then this
it's an exercise to see that this easily
gives us a correspondence between
um
these um
our universal
coordinates and independent sets
and therefore these quantities are the
same
and uh already this correspondence
allows us to to beat this bound
but what about this social
type
result so now
can we prove something
precise
and um
the answer is yes
and at least for the case of r equals
two that is for normal graphs
um
we have
turan's theorem
let's recall to run theorem so this says
that the unique graph with the smallest
possible number of edges with no
independent set of size k plus one
this is this
the
disjoint union of k clicks of size n
over k
so this is a unique extremal graph
and
zikov and other people so this is a
result which was approved many times in
different languages and so on
but
so zikoff extends this and proves that
actually this graph also uniquely
maximizes the number of independent sets
of any given size and also
in particular
uh maximizes the total number of
independent sets
so therefore we can just bound the
number of uh bound the number of
independences in the two-run graph and
uh this it gives us this value right so
because you can just pick at most one
vertex from each of these obliques
and you have k of them
and this gives us an exact but sarshela
type lemma for universal two dimension
and this is better than
what you can get from social and vc
damage
and it beats uh this barrier that i was
referring to so this is uh so this says
that we can arbitrarily approach and so
there is always some there is a size
there is a size threshold above which
you know you can
you can have arbitrarily large
u2 dimension
what about universal three and higher
um
so the situation is a little bit more
difficult here and
um
but it's also not completely hopeless so
um
what we can show is that um if
for for very high uh independence number
then the same result holds
so this disjoint union of edges
is the unique uh for for the correct
parameters that this joint union of
edges is the unique hyper graph which
maximizes the total number of
independent sets
and the proof is uh is not difficult
it's it's also non-trivial and
because
this statement it was known for um for
the
to run problem for hypergraphs that
this is the unique hypergraph
minimizing the number of edges with this
independence number
and but the proof is trivial there but
for for bounding the total number of
independent sets we have to do more work
and it's based on an observation which
allows us to
it's like it's sort of a uh
well it it's an
iterative process where
basically we can we pick an edge
we take an edge and we can show that
there is one vertex in this edge
the removal of which
[Music]
does not lose too many independent sets
so we do it one at a time until we
arrive at
an independent set
and of course which and independence
said of course we know how many vertices
it has therefore we know exactly how
many independent sets it has
and um
therefore
this gives us a total bound on the total
number of independences
so this this is uh
there is some
uh
issues here that but the details are in
the paper
but it's it's an intricate proof
and the general case well the the
general case uh seems to be that it's
this the same statement should hold that
is this joint union of clicks of almost
equal size should
give the
maximum number of independent sets
um
but note that this is different from the
usual term problem for hypergraphs
because they're
it's it's if it's open it's widely open
and
one reason is that
there are many conjectured uh
external instances
but here it really seems like if you
want to maximize the number of
independence sets
we also did some small
computer search on very small instances
so it really seems like there's no
reason not to take
clicks
okay
so
now let's go to the application
so the the complexity context uh in
which we were thinking was the context
of valiance program and depth three
circuits
so
we know that
super lean well so we don't have super
linear second lower bounds and
even if you put a logarithmic
depth restriction on them we still know
nothing
and
um
valiant
came up with some program for attacking
this problem
so let's consider this class of circuits
these are sigma 3k circuits these are or
and or circuits with bottom finding that
most k
so i like to think of them as an or of
kcnfs
valiant showed that with some nice graph
theoretical argument that if we have
a linear size log that circuit can be
written as
a sub exponential size
a depth three circuit
where the bottom funneling is
can be chosen to be into the epsilon
for any epsilon
so it means that if we have a truly
exponential lower bound for depth three
circuits we get super linear lower
bounds for log depth but but that three
lower bounds that we do know are only of
the form two to the square root n
so this is from switching one and so on
and
what is interesting is that if if we
only consider
constant bottom finding then strong
enough lower bounds
would also employ superlinear lower
bounds but for serious parallel circuits
and there are also some bounds known for
uh for constant finance and um
so they are the form two to the c and
over k this is c is a
fixed constant
and the state for the state of the
arctic can be chosen to be
pi squared over six
and this is from uh
the ppsc paper so the paper which gave
the famous k-set algorithm
in fact also gives a circuit lower bound
and if we fix the bottom finding to be
two in fact a
maximally large
door bound is known this is by pattory
sex and zane
and that's all we know
um
but recently
golovkin of colico van williams showed
that
such a lower bound for if
for bottom finding 16
would actually imply no lower bounds for
general circuits
so this 16 appears from the proofs so
it's possible that one can
prove such a result for uh smaller
bottom finding but but what is the
message here the message is that
this uh we should try to aim for results
of the of the form
this but
psc results but for a fixed constant
trying to prove
maximal uh lower balance
and this is somehow the motivation so we
were we were thinking about bottom
finding three
and uh
uh yeah this is
this is what you're thinking about
[Music]
um what do we know in
boundary depth circuits
well we have some tools we have
switching limits satisfiability putting
them off ppc and then it's strengthening
and ppsd specification lemma isolation
lemma so our shell element has been used
several times and so on
and this seems to be well maybe
i'm missing something but
this is pretty much our toolkit
and well and you know we have proved
whatever we could prove so far with them
um it seems that at least to me it seems
that
um we should somehow accept the
difficulty of circuit lower bounds and
just try to expand this toolkit
in a sense that if if we come up with
some tool which from which we can prove
something non-trivial i mean not
necessarily beating the state-of-the-art
circular but something
that from such something that you could
not prove with with the well-known
techniques then this should be
considered a
legitimate contribution and um
and maybe a first step and if we have
enough of these tools maybe finally we
can
prove a strong lower bill
and
this universal r dimension is can be
considered one such tool that we prove
we we have some
slower bounds
that
i do not know how else to prove
so let's start with bottom finding two
[Music]
um this is um
[Music]
so i'm going to tell you the main idea
of battery saxon zane
sure talk about what a projection is a
projection is an affine space defined by
equations of the of the following form
so it's you know it sets some variables
to constant and it
uh identifies some other variables or
says that they are
complement of each other
peturi saxons then showed that
uh
a 2c in a formula with sufficiently many
satisfying assignments
in particular contains and instead of
satisfying assignments a projection of
large dimension
now dimension so this is again this is a
fine space so you can think of a
dimension of an alpine space
and um
this is great because
this allows
us to derive from the over this lemma
a lower bound for affine dispersers and
recall that f1 disperses our functions
which are not constant under
a fine spaces of a given dimension
so in particular if it's a disperser for
sublinear dimension we get maximally
large
lower bounds
can we extend this result to three cnfs
by this result i mean this precise
statement about two cms so the answer is
no because if we want to find
projections
uh there are three cnfs
and we've written it's in the paper
with exponentially many satisfying
assignments but with projection
dimension bounded by a constant so this
statement does not hold for three cmfs
but but we have general affine
dispersers so is it maybe it's possible
to prove some some other theorem
says which says that instead of
projection we haven't
we have a general alpha in space of
damage large dimension can be proved
such a thing that i do not know
um but still we can do something with
our universal dimensions so um
the idea of batteries action zane is
that
the projection dimension is exactly the
vc dimension of the satisfying
assignments
and this relationship is proved by by
our understanding of two cmfs because
two cnfs can easily be described by
their implication diagram so
we can easily analyze satisfying
assignments
and um
but
the same tool allows us to analyze this
a little bit uh more closely and
actually we can show that
uh
the vc dimension is exactly universal
two-dimension for two cnms
so and what does this mean it means it
means that for two cnfs
there is no difference between being
shattered or being too universal
so this the this kind of syntactic
definition of a two cnf forces some form
of
semantic
constraints and this allows us to
improve sarshela for two cmfs and
therefore a tighter bound
for
the size of the three circuits but i'm
finding two
so this is tighter than
well this is tight
okay i don't know if it's tight in terms
of upper bound but it's
it's a better lower bound than uh than
peturi sex and zinc
and
one useful feature this again to to
demonstrate that it's a non-trivial so
what is the non-trivial aspect of this
because uh you can you can complain that
okay we could already prove maximal
lorry bounds for i found dispersers of
sublinear dimension this is not adding
anything
but
well this this bound now allows us to
prove non-trivial lower bounds for
worse off and disperses
if you care about them but again
the point was to demonstrate some
non-trivial application
in particular uh
if you consider inner product which is
uh
enough and disperser for dimension and
over two plus one
um
so this this result shows that if you
have a two cena which is consistent
within a product consistent means that
you know the
satisfying assignments are contained in
the ones of the function
then actually here we're looking at
really the
uh
negation of inner product for simplicity
then
then we have such a bound on the number
of satisfying assignments and
[Music]
and i will explain why this is
interesting later
what about three cnfs so as i mentioned
earlier uh
that was our main motivation to to look
at three cnafs
we can prove something here as well
although it's very very
humble
um
consider three c and f
consider a set of variables
which we can think of as coordinates
which are three universal for for the
set of satisfying assignments
then the complement of this set is a
hitting set
for for the cnf meaning that every
clause is hitting the complement and why
is that the reason is that if you have a
if you have a clause which is contained
in
in t
the three universality implies that you
can in particular falsify it and then
extend everything else to a satisfying
assignment but that's a contradiction
so
therefore a large uh universal three
dimension for satisfying assignments
gives us a small hitting set
and his hitting sets are useful for
three cms because if we restrict on a
hitting set
then uh the restriction is a two cnf and
we understand two cmfs
so in particular we can combine so if
you have sufficiently many satisfying
assignments we can find a heating set
and restrict it and then get it to cns
and then get a projection
so if we have sufficiently many
satisfying assignments then we get
uh projections
and well and we can find the proof and
we can prove a precise bound than this
and um
[Music]
it's also possible to prove this from
switching lemma but switching level
implies that if you have sufficiently
many satisfying assignments then in
particular
uh you can also find a large sub cube
but so quantitatively this is i cannot i
can prove something better
and i don't know any other proof
and under the conjecture that i
mentioned earlier about
the unique hypergraph maximizing the
number of independent sets
with a given independence number
then this this bound would even be
better
um so
let me uh
recall briefly what is what is the
general strategy improving this kind of
lower balance
the the template is the following so we
have some function f which we want to
prove that it's hard
uh once again uh we say that some
formula is consistent with with this
function if the set of satisfying
assignments are contained in the ones
and the main step is the following show
that every k c and f consistent with
this function
accepts at most
t at particular some uh parameter t many
satisfying assignments
then they get more bound
for this depth three bottom panel gains
k circuits and for the simple reason
that we can think of this such circuit
as
as a covering of the ones of the
function with
with
satisfying assignments of kc and
so this is what
ppc does
what ppsc does what this
[Music]
projection paper does and so on
the problem is that this
template fails in generals for
functions that
are interesting
and
again we're back to inner product and
this particular question of studying in
a product for bone fanning three was was
raised by
golovkin of kulikov and williams
i mentioned one of the results earlier
but already even for for bottom finding
two that the exact bound is not known
and and
it seems like it requires some some
new idea
um
so
our result our
universal two dimension implies that
every two cnf consistent with an inner
product accepts at most three to the n
over two and this is diet
so if you want to apply this template
now we get lower bound of
uh two to the 0.2 n
but actually we already know a better
lower bound and this follows from the
lower bound for parity which is in the
ppc paper
so what's going on
it seems like uh
maybe we need to show some form of
structural limit uh some structural
restriction on on certain two cnm's to
to understand these circuits
um so what we show is that this two cnf
which uh is consistent with inner
product and has maximum number of
satisfying assignments is unique so you
should think of it as some kind of a
touron type
it's an analog of two-run theorem for
two cnfs
and
the question is if we can
extend this further is there a stability
version of this so stability means that
maybe this object is not
achieving the
external quantity but but it's close to
it
so does it still have some particular
form and does this particular form allow
us to
to show that the circuit has to be large
uh we didn't uh
[Music]
we there we didn't
we didn't put any results uh along this
question in the paper
we didn't succeed but
we tried a bit and it's not trivial
and it feels like maybe
this should be something that we think
about so maybe we should a little bit be
become more uh
[Music]
so this template is a little bit
limiting so we should really try to
prove um
very
specific type of result for specific
functions and then maybe we can get some
more notes
anyway i hope you will read the paper
and
look at the details and thank you for
your your attention
you